hi guys today it's just one of those
days it started with such high hopes
this just did something probably bad I
was gonna wake up and edit my video this
morning and I've lost the footage that I
shot last night and on top of that my
camera battery is dead and I left the
charger at Mei Marie's house and I
realized that I just left my bag of
makeup oh my good my expensive trying to
overcompensate and be a real lady makeup
at a shoot I was at yesterday in the
bathroom so this is the only camera I
have decide phone camera and I have it
to do list of a billion things that I
have to get done let's just show you you
know when you get really frustrated with
things and you get really overwhelmed
and you look around you and you're like
oh my environment is a reflection of my
mental state right now would you care to
look at what's happening okay boom hey
that's my brain we got some recycling up
there there's some old meatballs that
didn't get eaten
that's a creature what else is going on
oh I'm in the middle of sending out some
books so I got some Oh projects going on
look you can see I tried to shoot the
draft is ashamed look that draft is just
me right now staring in the corners
banging your head against the wall
this one's just walking all over the
stuff it's one of those days so here's
what I'm gonna do I'm taking all of
these signs as an opportunity to not
make you a video today other than this
this is my message to say today's video
it's not gonna happen guys I'm gonna
clean up my environment and and get some
stuff done all of a sudden the strange
buzzing noise has appeared
that's curious okay I'm gonna take a
mental-health day but do not be
discouraged Friday Friday will be here
and my cameras will get charged and
great stuffs gonna happen next week and
also probably this week who knows this
hair yeah okay she's having a great time
I don't know sorry guys I'm back I I
decided tomorrow I will post a better
video I'll spend tonight shooting and
editing and recharging batteries and
doing all of that and there'll be a nice
video tomorrow yeah in the meantime
graces guide book calm - pre-order the
book and